dans on va découvrir avant notre ami
typhaine qui nous a amené quelques
quelques jolis livres parce que vous
allez nous emmener cette semaine loin
d'ici dans les vastes étendues dans les
plaines de l'ouest
on va parler cow boys et ça pour la
sélection de vous parler de western et
on va pas commencer par un cow boy on va
commencer par une femme kogure on peut
dire qu'elle habitait chez moi je sais
quand même peut-être à la plus connue
parmi les femmes aventurière de l'ouest
et françois roca lui consacre un
magnifique album chez albin michel
jeunesse
alors pourquoi magnifique parce que déjà
les illustrations sont splendides et
puis parce qu'on la découvre en maman et
parce que calamity jane y avait une
fille qui s'appelait jenny et qu'elle a
confié en fait à un couple pour qu'elles
vivent en famille mais cette cette
petite fille ignorent son existence
alors ça travaille beaucoup
calamity jane qui lui écrit en fait des
petites lettres dès qu'elle trouve un
morceau de papier incarne elle griffonne
puis elle lui raconte sa vie ses
rencontres avec les sioux sa vie un
petit peu difficile
et puis son isolement sa solitude et en
fait on a des extraits de cette lettre
dans ce livre et on découvre ainsi pas
cette femme qui est à la fois peut-être
brûlé indépendante mais qui est quand
même une maman et voilà qu'ils qui se
retrouve à un petit peu seul qui
aimerait bien revoir sa fille
on découvre qu'elle a connu à buffalo
bills voilà des grandes figures de
l'ouest et c'est vraiment du coup un
très joli livre pour peut-être les
petites filles qui se rêve indépendante
c'est vraiment très sympa je vous le
conseille et en fait ces lettres sont
des vraies lettres 1 40 ans après la
mort de deux là de l'aventurière
d'ailleurs vous avez désormais le
conseil n'ont donc mais ça c'est une
sélection mon avis je me sentais très
attentif à méditer parce que c'est vrai
que pour les filles comme pour les
garçons s'appellent oui mais c'est vrai
que ça peut être inspirant aussi et puis
le les westerns reviennent à la mode
figurait justement je vous avais un
autre western étonnant nous faire
découvrir avec une bande dessinée à
rebondissements avec des cowboys
buts ont tous raté ce soir à oui oui
c'est léo qui est ni plaidé cowboys ça
s'appelle la cour barry de rémy farnos
esseddyq édité par dont un par la maison
d'édition la pastèque
alors là figurez vous que ça commence
par une scène très étonnante
un cow boy très fier de son dernier
casse qui se dit je vais fêter ça une
bouteille à la main il enterre son butin
et le lendemain matin impossible de le
retrouver
oui effectivement ce principe donc non
c'est pas un super cowboys il a trois
jours pour leur trouver sinon son frère
va lui faire sa fête
évidemment et là s'en suit une série de
rebondissements tous ceux plus loufoques
les uns que les autres
alors ce qui est très intéressant de
cette bande dessinée c'est l'alternance
de couleur vous voyez le jaune un peu
soutenue due au mode touche au palazzo
les airs et puis les personnages qui
sont à peine esquissés ce qui laisse
planer un certain mystère autour d'eux
d'ailleurs on va découvrir cet orphelin
là c'est mystérieux qui va se révéler un
atout dans la manche de ces cobayes
complètement raté une voiture donc je
veux le conseil il ya un rebondissement
jusqu'à la dette et donc vraiment c'est
assez sympa on va dire pour les
électeurs à partir de 8 ans et que jusqu
aux adultes évidemment avec leur sauce
apple comme boris pas avec mon accent
voilà ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'al
fier vous avez alors là je suis pas le
seul isabelle vous savez vous en angola
bond et bernie au club ça veut dire quoi
mais c'est un veau parce que cowboys et
qui gardent les vaches d'accord que j'ai
pigé parfait vous me parlez de western
deux cow boy pour le dernier vous nous
emmenez toujours dans l'ouest américain
voyait partout en australie
ces pays des kangourous c'est pas
vraiment le pays des cow boys et bien si
mais vous avez jamais vu ces étendues
sauvages avec des combos effectivement
et grimpe peu de bovins et des cowboys
aussi qu'ils les gardent non ça vous
chers aux bonbons ce qu'il fallait je
vous emmène à la rencontre de ned kelly
c'est lui et c'est une légende l'album
dark vador plutôt je trompe penneteau
leur écoute et celle ci la gravure vous
inspire scène on en jugera sur cnet
kelly c'est aussi un cow boy mais c'est
un cobaye australien et c'est en fait un
père et une fille donc marie ève de
grève et jean-jacques de greef jean ont
décidé de revisiter cette histoire alors
les gravures sont du père
l'histoire et de la fille et c'est
vraiment un très très beau livre c'est
un roman graphique qui veut raconter
bien l'histoire de deux fils de colon
irlandais parti un peu comme on dira à
la dérive parce que ils n'ont pas
d'argent nous qui commettent de petits
larcins et puis finalement après la
prison leur tête est mis à prix est mise
à prix et voilà ça va ça finit en vraies
histoires de cow boy avec cavale coups
de feu
voilà mais les gravures sont magnifiques
et c'est ce qui fait l'originalité de ce
livre c'est plutôt pour les ados et les
adultes
mais voilà comme ça il y en a plus un
pager lecture seule sur le terrain avec
trois livres les cowboys et les indiens
qui sont à la fête
donc on enfile son chapeau et ses
santiags